(clap)
(silly music)
- Three words, wow.
- Okay, um.
- Could one of the words be hyphenated?
- [Interviewer] Yep.
- Am I a Monica?
Is this a Friends test?
- No.
- Oh, yeah, what?
- Oh God.
Is this what it is?
I'm curious to see who my friends are.
- Oh, yeah!
- Hilarious, big hearted, incredible.
- Hilarious, genuine, and unpredictable.
- Funny, kind, sing-songy.
- (laughs) That was Garrick.
Garrick said sing-songy (laughs).
I wish I believed them (laughs).
- Genuine,
unstoppable, and
iconic.
- Unpredictable, colorful, and kind.
Maybe a ho?
- Yes (laughs).
- Confident, inspiring,
beautiful inside and out.
- Wow!
I have some nice friends!
I would never describe myself
in that many nice words.
- This is the most pressure
I've ever had in my life.
Funny, smart,
zesty.
- Did Ryan say zesty?
Who said zesty?
- Cool, artist, opinionated.
- (laughs) That's true.
- Creative, kind, passionate.
- Oh, that's very sweet.
It's nice to know that
I guess other people
see you the way you see yourself.
- Beautiful, genuine, and strong.
- Goddess, angel baby, darling.
- Funny, lovely, and courageous.
- Considerate, intelligent, and sassy.
- Energetic, comical, independent.
Loud, intelligent, and funny.
Extra.
- Wow!
That's the most precious
thing in the world!
Also, I'm glad they don't think I'm funny.
- Hot, cool, and nerdy.
- So I'm just a lot of temperatures.
- Visionary, driven, and
maybe a bit of a diva.
- Passionate, brilliant, and stubborn.
He is so fucking stubborn.
- Did fucking Zack say that?
Yeah, fucker.
Can I quickly pick three
words for each of them?
Keith is waffle, pancakes, chicken.
Ned is married, married, married.
And then Zack is
ow,
my,
back.
(laughs)
(quiet music)